foreign
ly
finally a piece of clothing
that has a message on it
that I can completely agree with oh I
still wouldn't wear any logos of my
clothing but I can get down with this
message this is a hooded sweatshirt if
you're watching the video version of the
podcast you'll see this but I'll read it
to you if you're just listening to the
audio the back of this sweatshirt says
stop trying to be liked by everyone
you don't even like everyone
isn't that funny because like we don't
like everyone but we want everyone to
like us
how fascinating is that it's wild man
and so what do we do we buy things to
impress people
that we don't know or we don't like or
some people we may never like yeah and
we use money we don't have to buy the
things we don't even want ourselves we
certainly don't need them but I really
want you to like me yeah and I'll only
be happy if you like me oh you like me
now I need you to like me oh you like me
that's great but I need you to like me
and as soon as one person doesn't like
me what do I do I don't say oh I'm so
thankful for all the people that like me
yeah oh I'm so miserable because that
one person that I'm fixated on doesn't
like me and that's the tricky thing
about selling your soul it's easy to go
with the Hollywood stereo type of
thinking that selling your soul is all
about the money you're more likely to
sell your soul for the
risk-free life of not being criticized
by a complete stranger we sell our souls
in the form of what we don't say what we
don't do what we pretend to believe
because we don't want people to dislike
us nothing to do with money but where's
your soul um so how many did you buy
I bought one for everyone here because I
really want you to like me no you know
it's interesting like I still want
everyone to like me because I I maybe
that's just ingrained in me for whatever
reason but when someone doesn't like me
um I don't get too upset about it
because uh I really like myself and that
is how I've been able to get over that
need to be liked by everyone well that's
the judgment is a mirror because what
you're saying is I'm worthy of being
liked I'm worthy of Love even if you
don't give it to me I am worthy but I
don't need it in order for me to be
fulfilled absolutely yeah for our sucky
ad segment I'm gonna skip it this week
but I want to talk about two things
really quickly the reason I'm skipping
it is one of our listeners Alyssa she
sent in an email and she said you've got
to listen to Jordan harbinger's cringy I
think it was Pepsi Zero ad or something
and so well I'm actually gonna save it
for when next time we bring him back
onto the podcast so I can call out his
cringy ad in front of his face instead
of talking about him uh just on the
podcast because he's a friend of ours
but I'm still willing to criticize him
in person although I will say this
not all ads are created equal some to me
are just gross or disgusting or boring
others however are just like I'd rather
they not be around but for episode 400
which is not too far around the corner I
finally found an ad I didn't look for it
it just showed up one day I finally
found an ad
but not only I liked but I appreciated
it and it was a really weird Out of Body
Experience for me because you know how I
feel about advertisements but I found
one so stay tuned episode 400 which I
think is maybe eight episodes from now I
have an advertisement that fell into my
lap that I actually enjoyed is it a
LeBron James ad
definitely not because I'm not going to
play angels have again with that one no
I will tell you that LeBron James's ads
for Ruffles are awful and it's so
beneath him being either the greatest or
one of the greatest athletes of all time
and then oh I try the flaming hot poison
no thank you sounds delicious you're a
billionaire you don't need to convince
me to eat poison
I'd be fine without it and you'd be fine
without it as well dude I didn't even
start liking LeBron until the
commercials he is so lovable in his
commercials I'm serious when I started
watching Broad and commercials I'm like
oh this guy's really funny how'd you
feel about Michael Jordan's Haynes
commercials though loved it I wear hands
to this day
do you eat McDonald's too
bleep that out bleep out that brand
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free